livraison au 30ème signal registre ouais
vous pouvez me tenir ça s'il vous plaît
ceci est une bombe je viens juste de
l'armée ne bougez pas elle est équipée
d'un capteur de mouvement si j'entends
une alarme ou une sirène je fais sauter
la bombe c'est clair bien j'en ai pas
pour longtemps
que les choses soient bien claires
rien à voir avec les gendarmes et les
voleurs
l'ennemi est invisible et omniprésent
qu'est-ce que vous préférez
vous prendre pour le héros de l'histoire
ou être raisonnable et nous aider à
sauver le monde
les données c'est le moteur de tout tu
crois simplement t'acheter des
chaussettes mais ils savent pour qui tu
votes et pour quelle raison
pourquoi moi je sais que je peux te
faire confiance c'est toi qui m'a appris
à me méfier de tout le monde
l'espionnage économique c'est moche
comme façon de s'enrichir vous êtes en
train de m'accuser de quelque chose
quelqu'un voulez-vous tuer parce que
vous avez trouvé quelque chose ça fait
partie des risques du métier personne
n'a jamais pu conquérir une puissance
mondiale démocratique telle que la nôtre
il a vu que notre pays était divisé par
la colère
la moitié du travail est déjà faite
cette fois je pense qu'il y a peut-être
eu trop de possibilités
j'arrive plus à faire la différence
entre ce qui est vrai ce qui n'est pas
tu fais définitivement n'importe quoi
cette fois John
il y a quelque chose d'énorme qui se
déroule dans cette société
[Applaudissements]
du plan une confiance mutuelle
inébranlable
ça va être douloureux
[Musique]